[Music]
i'm remiss i must i should have done
this right when you came out but i
didn't congratulations you just got
engaged and i think that's fantastic
tell us
it was wonderful tell us what was the
what was the experience like of getting
engaged
it was a shocker i was very surprised
we've been together for five years
almost five years and he managed to
surprise me which is wonderful and um
but also kind of weird at the same time
because
i went in i blacked out i did black out
and he came it all happened he was
talking to me and i saw a box and it
just went
black
so i don't know what happened he roofied
you was what he did he drugged me
are you seriously blacked out i know it
went well because we're planning a
wedding so i know that i must have said
all the right things well when you came
to or was he like you said yes yeah
you said you're gonna do it and you're
going to do it
and it's going to be like this
are you being serious that you blacked
out or you just got so excited that you
kind of yeah it was just such a surreal
moment i mean that i mean it you know it
happens and you when especially when you
don't you don't know that it's gonna
happen it just i don't know it took my
breath away and i was very uh stunned
and shocked and excited is your family
excited are they gonna is your mom
getting into it because moms love to get
involved my mom is now like i told you
last time i was here she got threw up in
a yoga class which was sad i'm sorry i
didn't mention that again it was classic
television
[Laughter]
and um but now she's like okay that's it
i'm really i'm gonna get into serious
shape for this wedding i'm gonna look
great so she's doing zumba so i called
her and i said so are you excited for
zumba tonight it's just it's a latin
yeah
i don't know what zumba is because
it's in the news a lot now yeah there's
like people are latin
inspired fitness dance classes but she
goes she goes i'm going to do it half
speed because i don't want to be sore
tomorrow
i go but what do you mean half speed how
do you do a latin dance it's like if we
kick out this way she's going to go no
so she's doing she's doing zumba and
she's yeah she's kind of doing it half
speed i like when you're doing it uh
it's but it's like a sexy kind of dance
it is it's like you know kicks and
swirls and spins and you know and men i
wonder how men do it i have not been do
men go to zumba classes or do they only
go
to look at women you know that one in
maine yes where the prostitute was was
teaching
i think men were going to that one yeah
i'm sure
suspiciously
i'm not here to dance you know why i'm
here
i think i'm going to try that zumba yeah
of course they're all in names
but it's not forbidden
now i want to try it
we have a clip here from happy endings
uh and congratulations on the show
people really love it you guys are
having terrific success anything we need
to know for this clip um yeah well dave
and i um my ex-fiance on the show are
back together and this is us sort of
explaining to the rest of the gang that
we're uh
we're together now let's take a look
well big news out of this corner these
two are going to meet with a real estate
agent and look at apartments today stop
before you start just stop right in your
trash we know what you're thinking okay
then we're moving too fast but we can't
go backwards we just can't yeah jane
you're probably like
bad idea i'm gonna do my kegel exercises
and penny you're probably like omg this
is so not amazing yeah and max is all
like you guys are still stupid and so
not fierce
and then brad is like oh hell no you two
why isn't moving in together jive ass
turkeys don't even sound like that
wait
[Applause]
[Music]
that wasn't the right place it wasn't
the right clip i'm surprised enough for
god's sake and you have a you have a
parrot on the show i do have a parrot
and this parrot is he's racist and
homophobic
the only the only heart i love that idea
is a parrot that's the way they are yeah
yeah his only hobby is racism so it's
tough you know to get him interested in
others actually when i heard that idea i
thought it's a very funny idea a racist
homophobia
who embarrasses everything yeah we do a
lot of things together too on the show
which is a lot of fun we did like uh
i brought a picture of us as thumb and
louise and we just do a lot of fun
things we have that i think you guys
dressed up as thumb and louise on the
show